there's a new GTA update out and it's
worth checking out Rockstar brings us
the high life update with plenty of
upper-class goodies as well as some
major game changers that will make life
in Los Santos better but before we step
out in public and see what's new in Los
Santos get a haircut and freshen up
because it's Miller time go ahead and
take a stroll down to your local ripoff
Posen B and flip through 32 new suit
options take the time to be original or
let the pros take over and start with
the basic outfit looking good but now
you can look even better with a handful
of new actions let's see what we got
here thumbs up hey there good-looking
and it's a wind-up you're hot you're
totally hot yeah air thrust one hot air
thrust to anyone see that
jazz hands bring sarcasm to surrendering
the she's in this season and then
there's Doc which I think it means like
hey I'm gonna poke your eye out
other than those you can taunt your
enemies with slow clap and facepalm but
most importantly you can now finally
mine gold and GTA online app s enough of
that
let's take a look at some of the new
high-end real estate that hit the market
all of the apartments in highlife are
roughly around half a mil and I went
with the downtown flat with this sweet
living room and big screen TV kitchen
huge bathroom walk-in closet king-size
bed for eye poking and the view well it
sucks Construction Yard you kidding it
good thing you can now have two
properties because this is both all-new
properties have 10 car garages and this
one clearly needs some filling thank god
the high life update brings us four new
vehicles such as the Dinka thrust
motorcycle Hunley SUV Mascaro
sports car and the insanely popular
supercar pegassi zentorno
if those are too pricy for you you can
now purchase an additional ten vehicles
from story mode like the Ocelot f6 20
but you're better off finding that on
Street before you hit those streets stop
by any nation and check out the new
bullpup rifle it's got some solid damage
but lacks an accuracy so if you're
serious about it well buy the grip and
scope add-ons to make up for it yet what
has really changed up firefights are the
body armor updates you can now purchase
and use more than one set of body armor
similar to what snacks do to your help
making it essentially harder to take
down other players who have armor ready
to go so what else is new
well you got a couple of new landraces
with the newly added vehicles and a
handful of other new contact missions
but what this update will really go down
in history for are its attempts to make
Los Santos less frustrating it's called
mental state and it's pretty great the
stat keeps track of your behavior and
allows other players to determine what
kind of player you are if you're a fan
of murdering and show no mercy
your blip on the radar will reflect just
that the rhetoric players blip is the
more caution you should use towards them
it's a great way to prepare yourself
when you see a player flying down a road
in your direction
unfortunately killing pedestrians do
factor into your psychotic State so
keeping the readout of your reticle
means you need to be some kind of star
citizen
there are plenty of more bug fixes and
additions to this update but there's
only so much I can give you an a video
check out rockstars newswire for all of
the changes thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]